alerta roja epidemiológica en bogotá en
una colombia que inmersa en la tercera
ola vive su peor momento de la pandemia
el pasado jueves el ministerio de salud
del país confirmó que se habían superado
los 70 mil fallecidos por kobe 19 y
desde entonces se han marcado récords
diarios de fallecidos alcanzando los 465
este pasado domingo 105 mil 614 casos
están activos en la actualidad con estos
datos en la mano y el aumento de la
ocupación uncía hasta el 91 por ciento
en la capital alcaldesa de bogotá
claudia lópez decretó el domingo por la
tarde la alerta roja epidemiológica por
actor en este momento no sólo sistema
hospitalario sino toda gota esta alerta
roja porque tenemos alta ocupación ya
91% ocupación poca capacidad digamos de
ampliación y además muy alta transmisión
del virus las nuevas medidas incluyen la
suspensión por dos semanas del retorno a
la presencialidad en colegios y jardines
infantiles toques de queda desde las
ocho de la noche y cierre de
establecimientos esenciales y no
esenciales desde las siete de la noche
además habrá ley seca pico y cédula y
confinamiento estricto de jueves
hasta las 4 de la mañana del lunes estas
medidas se unen a las decretadas
anteriormente en medellín la segunda
ciudad del país en donde el ejército de
la policía patrullan las calles para
hacer cumplir el toque de queda vamos a
estar en los barrios haciendo un control
de alguna manera pedagógico frente a la
población civil recordándoles en estos
momentos la situación del cob y no solo
a nivel nacional sino a nivel mundial en
este tercer pico la idea es interactuar
con estas personas que están de alguna
manera incumpliendo este decreto todas
estas medidas se dan antes de una
convocatoria de paro nacional para este
próximo miércoles 28 en respuesta a una
nueva reforma tributaria del gobierno de
iván duque